[Musique]
combien y at-il de fermes certifiées
biologiques dans le monde selon les plus
récentes statistiques on compte à
l'échelle mondiale près de 3 millions
d'exploitations agricoles certifiées bio
entre 2000 et 2010 est le nombre de
fermes bio a été multiplié par 12 dans
le monde et la surface cultivée en bio a
plus que triplé
fin 2010 c'est près de 70 millions
d'hectares étaient en culture biologique
c'est une hausse de 20% par rapport à
l'année précédente
du jamais vu mais malgré cette forte
hausse la place du bio demeurent
marginales 1,4 pour cent des terres
cultivées dans le monde sont en régie
biologique mais la place occupée par le
bio varient beaucoup d'un continent et
d'un pays à l'autre sans surprise de
grands pays ont de grandes terres bio
l'australie est de loin le pays qui en
détient le plus plus de 35 millions
d'hectares c'est plus de la moitié de
toutes les superficies bio de la planète
là bas ces terres sont surtout consacré
à l'élevage
viennent ensuite l'argentine et la chine
le canada en a près de 1,2 million
d'hectares mais c'est dans de petits
pays que l'on trouve la plus grande
proportion des terres consacrées au bio
au liechtenstein c'est près de 40% en
autriche 24% en comparaison au canada
moins de 2% des terres sont en culture
biologique
en fait dans une quinzaine de pays
principalement en europe plus de 10% des
terres agricoles sont en bio